right we start with the Fox News Alert
there is absolutely zero evidence that
President Trump ever colluded with
Russia in any way shape manner or form
and now Robert mullahs merry band of
Trump hating Democratic sycophants are
completely and totally desperate to find
anything something on president Trump
late last night the New York Times
released a report allegedly detailing
questions that robert muller wants to
ask trump before the investigation
concludes if any of these leaked
questions are true be warned
Muller is laying a huge perjury trap for
the President of the United States which
means two things one he has nothing and
two it proves everything I've been
saying about him and Andrew Weissman and
company two of America's top attorneys
are now sounding the alarm what's this
the questions are very artfully drawn
they are written as open-ended questions
they're not cross-examination questions
they're not sharp questions designed to
confront and test they're really
designed to let him ramble and talk and
I suspect that's the strategy of the
special counsel because they know that
maybe president Trump's weakness if they
were to ask him direct tough questions
to which he can answer yes or no that
might not give them the advantage
they're seeking the questions are an
intrusion into the president's Article
two powers under the Constitution to
fire any executive branch employee to
ask questions as mr. Muller
apparently proposes to do about what the
president was thinking when he fired
Comey or Flynn or anybody else is an
outrageous sophomoric juvenile intrusion
into the president's unfettered power to
fire anyone in the executive branch it
is a symptom of how ridiculous this
appointment was by Rod Rosenstein when
he made the appointment with no evidence
of a crime
Joe did Jennifer Alan Dershowitz are
exactly right this is a perjury trap for
President of the United States and even
more frightening or the contents of this
inquiry now note all the questions that
include the term what did the president
think what did the president think about
James Comey what does the president
think about Jeff Sessions recusal what
does the president think about the
special counsel well I have a question
for robert muller tonight
when did thinking or thoughts ever
become a crime when did the United
States start regulating what may or may
not be in a person's mind are we now
going to criminalize thoughts this list
of insane juvenile ridiculous questions
goes on including one question about a
statement to our friend Maria Bartiromo
the president's reaction to news reports
and what discussions Trump had about
terminating the special counsel excuse
me
he never terminated him and again more
questions about the president's thought
process now remember this is supposed to
be originally was supposed to be about
Russia collusion and investigation not
some persecution of the President on
ridiculous thought patterns rush
limbaugh captured it well today he said
the president should only agree to a
Muller interview if in fact president
Trump's gets the Hillary Clinton
treatment let's take a look
if Trump could secure the same identical
circumstances that were granted to
Hillary Clinton then why not sit down
for the interview and answer the
questions but of course I speak
facetiously because everybody knows that
Donald Trump is not going to get the
Hillary Clinton treatment extended by
James Comey you know not under oath not
recorded pretty much meaningless send in
a pro Trump person like Peter struck
interviewed Hillary you know that's
right if we have a fair system of
Justice President Trump should
absolutely get the Hillary treatment for
any interview with the FBI and just like
Hillary Clinton's interview after the
exoneration was meant written months
later Oh
Trump's interview should be conducted
not under oath not recorded not be
transcribed and the exoneration written
months in advance and oh yeah someone
with a pro Trump bias let's say me I'll
conduct the questioning now if Hillary
click are the great one Mark Levin good
idea now
she gets the Clinton treatment
anti-trump FBI agent Peter struck for
the interview maybe I don't know we have
a good choice of people lots of
conservatives that can interview him all
right none of this is ever going to
happen we know that we now know sadly in
America we have a two-tier justice
system we don't have equal justice under
the law equal application of our laws
while the president is targeted in a
totally off the rails witch-hunt Hillary
Clinton James Comey Andrew McCabe all
these other deep state actors have never
been charged with a crime despite
mountains of evidence that we have for
example despite her total exoneration
from the FBI our friend Fox News legal
analyst Greg Jarrett will join us
tonight he has revealed multiple serious
crimes that Hillary Clinton should be
charged with starting with 18 USC 793
miss handling destroying classified
documents 18 USC 1505 the obstruction of
justice
remember bleach pit deleted emails
busted up devices no charges over the
multiple crimes related to the her
campaign shady practices surrounding the
steel dossier next up let's look at
James Comey well he's not under any
criminal investigation as of now
shouldn't he at least face scrutiny over
18 USC 641 the theft of government
property or records after he took his
trump memos outside of the FBI
what about 18 USC 1924 the miss handling
a classified information and remember
when James Comey lied to Congress about
not signing off on Clinton's exoneration
letter months before that interview took
place that's against the law
18 USC 1621 and we got Andrew McCabe
House Republicans have now referred
McCabe as did the IG for multiple crimes
over lying to the FBI and McCabe was
fired for lying to the FBI
let's see Oh general Flynn why isn't he
been charged with a crime in this case
now of course don't hold your breath for
an investigation into Loretta Lynch Lisa
Paige Peter struck or any of these other
anti-trump deep state actors now what's
behind this sadly in the United States
of America today is a two-tiered system
of justice it is
the deep state hates who you chose to be
your president
they are hell-bent on seeing Donald
Trump D legitimize and hopefully on
their side removed from office obviously
that means they don't want him to
succeed and that would mean even if
Americans suffer in the process of
breaking this week a group of wealthy
secret donors get this they poured as
much as fifty million dollars into an
investigation of President Trump after
his 2016 election based on the dossier
now this is in the house Intel committee
report get this these top-secret anti
Trump donors even utilized the services
of Christopher Steele the foreign
national the author of the dirty dossier
that we now know was filled with Russian
lies now without a doubt this deep
stated conducting a full-scale political
attempt to take down this president and
perhaps the most pathetic deep state
actor of all James Comey well the guy
that refused to come on this show I
offered him four hours of airtime he's
continuing his anti Trump book tour and
he's actually claiming that Trump's
criticism of the deep State is dangerous
for the country how dare he how dare he
be honest no president has faced this
before now Comey also took some time to
fantasize about what if the Deep States
choice his choice
when in fact he exonerated Hillary
Clinton when he knew she committed
crimes and wrote the exoneration before
investigation but he's thinking but what
if Hillary had actually won
take a look what would your life be like
if she won
I also don't know the answer that I
think I would still be the FBI director
and the reason I say that is someone
asked me to compare the two and is it's
too hard for me to compare the two
except Secretary Clinton is someone
deeply enmeshed in meshed in the rule of
law respect for institutions a lawyer
and so given that background I'm
reasonably confident that even though
she was unhappy with decisions the FBI
had made she would not fire the FBI
director as a result I don't even think
she would have kept you around now let's
turn to another anti-trump actor Deputy
Attorney General rod Rosen Steve now the
freedom caucus chairman mark meadows has
been on the show a lot along with
several other House Republicans they
have drafted articles of impeachment
against Rosenstein over the extremely
slow release or just flat-out
obstruction regarding subpoenaed
documents related to the Clinton email
investigation and of course the dossier
and FISA abuse and the Russia
investigation today Rosenstein fired
back trashing Congress Congress has a
constitutional duty and authority of
oversight mister Rosenstein I would
think you read that in your Constitution
take a look they can't even resist
leaking their own drafts care to
elaborate on that I saw that draft I
mean I don't know who wrote it there
were people who have been making threats
privately and publicly against me for
quite some time and I think they should
understand by now the Department of
Justice is not going to be extorted
we're going to do what's required by the
rule of law and any kind of threats that
anybody makes are not going to affect
the way we do our job
and Congress is going to do their
constitutional job and demand you hand
over the documents they have subpoenaed
a long time ago congressman meadows
responding on Twitter writing if he
believes being asked to do his job is
extortion then rod Rosenstein should
step aside and allow us to find a new
Deputy Attorney General preferably one
who was interested in transparency and
I'll add also the law also breaking
tonight chairman Bob good
chairman Gowdy they are requesting more
information from the Justice Department
surrounding fired FBI director Comey's
friend Daniel Richmond is the guy who
used this special designation in the FBI
to leak information to the press which
of course we don't call me wanted is
Rosenstein gonna cooperate on this one
I'm not holding my breath next up we
have yet even more examples to bring you
from the abusively biased press in this
country and their aged old tactic called
biased by omission and according to a
report from News Buster's Tonight on
Monday
well network news broadcasts ABC CBS NBC
guess what they completely failed to
mention South Koreans president moon
suggested Donald Trump should win the
Nobel Peace Prize they never mentioned
it in fact according to News Buster's
the only mention of a Nobel Peace Prize
was used by ABC and NBC to mock Trump
supporters who started chanting in
Michigan Nobel Nobel during his rally
over the weekend and while the media is
not ignoring Trump serious progress on
the world stage which they always do
they're mourning the tragic plight of
the caravan of migrants at our southern
border that want to enter this country
illegally that don't respect our
sovereignty take a look crisis at the
border a caravan with more than a
hundred migrants seeking asylum arriving
at the US border with Mexico but told
there's no room up and this is literally
the end of the road for these migrants
you can see them camped out here by the
dozens against the morning chill they're
literally sleeping up against the border
termo border showdown the standoff
escalates over that caravan of migrants
from Central America
announced by the president there now the
US border will they be turned away
there's a caravan of Central American
migrants traveling for more than a month
is that the us-mexico border trying to
cross US officials are trying to keep
the group of nearly 200 people out they
want asylum but have not been allowed to
start the application process now with
the media is failing to emphasize is the
Department of Justice has filed criminal
illegal entry charges to eleven members
of this Caravan including one felony
charge to a person who was previously
deported many of these migrants scaled
the border fence in California look at
that after making their way from Central
America unabated through Mexico Mexico
that routinely throws people out or
throws them in prison if they enter
illegally from El Salvador Nicaragua or
Central America these images you're
watching the wall climbing the attempt
to illegally cross the border is a clear
and obvious indication of how many of
these migrants value our laws respect
our sovereignty and what's worse
Mexico's total inaction it shows what
kind of so-called
ally we're dealing with south of the
border